really an announcement of significance
yesterday but not perhaps quite as
significant as many had been led to
believe can you just explain why the
eastern leg of hs2 is now not going
ahead and while that high-speed rail
link between leeds and manchester
similarly will not be going ahead as
promised
uh that's just not accurate reporting
actually uh this is a 96 billion pound
package it's the first time spending
that sort of money it's being called a
robbery
96 billion pounds package it does
include three new high-speed lines
that's from crew to manchester from
warrington across to the west of
yorkshire and a new line
from birmingham to nottingham and derby
so there are three new sections of high
speed line there are nearly 400 miles of
electrification of line lots of other
upgrades including digital signaling and
actually the thing will matter to people
in the end is if you are in manchester
which is where i am this morning you'll
have a 33 minute journey across to leeds
if you're in bradford you'll have a 12
minute journey to leeds so we're talking
now about some really fast journey times
due to this multi-billion pound package
of upgrades and spending and high speed
lines
i i mean i might be forgetting things
but the prime minister to my
recollection stood in manchester next to
a train and said i'm going to deliver on
my commitment to that vision with a
pledge to fund the leads to manchester
route you yourself at a policy exchange
event six months ago said we are going
to complete hs2 and include hs2 on the
eastern leg to leads those were both
promises made by you and the prime
minister those promises have not been
fulfilled why not
that they're absolutely being fulfilled
first of all we're producing that 30
minute around 30 minute journey from
manchester leeds or to give you another
example manchester liverpool uh in uh 35
minutes so we're giving that
interconnectivity we said we wanted to
create that kind of connection that you
would have perhaps if it was in the
south in the north and when it comes to
hs2 we're going to deliver hs2 trains
and look the best way to do that into
leeds
the plan for hs2 was conceived 15 years
and more ago and we always said what we
want to do is make sure it actually
integrates with these plans for northern
powerhouse rail which we are building
that is the line which goes across
including high-speed rail which will
make those dramatic journey time
differences
as well as midlands what's called the
midlands rail hub uh the ability to
connect the midlands up much better um
so for example you'll be able to travel
from our biggest cities in the midlands
birmingham um say to to nottingham uh in
in in under half an hour that sort of
thing so 27 minutes so you know this is
a massive plan it spends 96 billion
pounds uh over 50 billion of that is is
is new money into this plan um and so
everywhere no matter where you are
you're going to get uh you know uh as
good or or better journey times nearly
everywhere across the midlands and north
it's really actually and you are a new
minister and you are very surprised
and you're very free to argue that point
but the level of cognitive dissonance on
display this morning is nothing if not
impressive did or did not the prime
minister say to the commons this year i
can certainly confirm that we're going
to develop the eastern leg as well as
the whole of hs2
um which is exactly what we're doing and
i think it's been misunderstood the way
that's been
created so the eastern leg will be
developed as i said there'll be a new
brand new high speed line i think it
covers about 35 percent of the distance
we'll then look to utilize and upgrade
for example the midland main line so if
you were taking the journey to sheffield
it will be exactly the same under this
plan as it would have been under the
original hs2 plan but sheffield and many
other places will be served in between
so this is now bringing in a lot more
communities who wouldn't have had the
benefits of high speed with this measure
and as i say there's 100 million pounds
in there not only to look at how to take
trains hs2 trains i should say into
leads but also
how to give leads a a a transit system
because that is the biggest uh town city
rather in europe without its open
transit system so all of that and much
much else is included in here and the
only disconnect are some of the uh
complaints from i have to say largely uh
labour leaders uh who are completely
misleading people because when they
actually look at the list of journey
times what their uh what their residents
will see is they'll be able to get
around a lot faster from virtually every
place to virtually every place i have to
say i think the idea that it's only
labour leaders that have been
criticizing this is similarly white of
the mark minister hugh merriman your
colleague from the conservative party
who chairs the transport select
committee accused the prime minister of
selling perpetual sunlight and then
leaving it to others to explain the
arrival of moonlight at robbie moore
another 2019 to a 2019 tory intake
mp he said that the region has been left
completely short changed ministers need
to do much much more kevin hollenrich
said
that bradford will be paying an economic
price for generations sir edward lee now
describing hs2 as a white elephant
wouldn't it now without a leg i mean
these are colleagues of yours within the
conservative party so i can list
regional mayors as well all of whom who
say that this plan is a retrograde step
namely a city in the north okay well
this is welcoming the changes to the
plans
right first of all a lot of the the
names you mentioned sir lee for example
have been long-term opponents of uh hs2
so you know there are people who you're
quoting and only partially quoting
because in each of those cases they also
went on to welcome different aspects the
thing about rail is uh you know if you
if the train service doesn't come to
your community then quite rightly you
will always speak up about it but for
example that quote about bradford is
simply wrong a 12-minute journey to go
from bradford to leeds 12 minutes this
connects these two great northern cities
up in a way that uh you know
even even towns uh in the south are not
connected up this is far better
you asked me you asked me the last
question let me answer it name you some
mayors you said you gave me the
challenge yes i was with andy street
yesterday birmingham a big winner in
this nottingham a big winner darby does
very well anything north of that mayor's
uh in yes of course ben houchin who i
spoke to uh yesterday about this is that
hs2 according to ben hodgson is now a
waste of money billions of pounds
but ben halton was never in favor of hs2
it never was going to run uh to tease
valley but what he white massively
welcomes
and i don't think we've even discussed
yet is the billions of pounds of
upgrades to the east coast mainline
things like the digitization of
signaling which will mean that those
journey times anywhere up the east coast
anywhere on the east coast even into
scotland will be massively improved by
this investment and really there's the
only disconnect here is 96 billion
pounds being spent virtually every area
receiving as good or better service than
would have been under the original plans
and then uh anyone really saying oh oh
we don't get anything out of this it's
simply not true you know manchester to
lead 33 minutes i mean that is a huge
improvement from where we are you know
manchester to liverpool 35 minutes these
are massive improvements for where we
are from where we are at the moment and
they complete a northern powerhouse rail
which includes high-speed lights
just to reiterate though newcastle not
supporting it liverpool not supporting
it leeds manchester sheffield bradford
as i just quoted none of them are are
particularly happy with this i mean i
was speaking last night to the editor of
the yorkshire post who actually carried
an article by the prime minister
yesterday morning i i just don't believe
that you understand the depth of anger
that exists this morning about another
u-turn by this government he told me
this this is a betrayal of the north as
severe as missy stature's decimation of
northern industry in the 1980s
well well look i mean if you are in
newcastle then be aware that uh rather
than taking 81 minutes so an hour and 21
it will take an hour and a quarter uh to
get from say newcastle to leeds and
that's without taking into account that
the massive advantages of the
electrifications uh further south uh as
well and the digitization so this would
have been the only uh this will have
been the the only uh time in history
where massively improving everybody's
rail services uh would have been counted
as a betrayal it's a strange approach
but if you live in those areas i urge
you to download the integrated rail plan
rather than listening to what these
people are saying download the
integrated braille plan pages 18 and 19
will list your town or city and it will
show the speed of improvement for the
journey that you'll now be getting and
uh if you still feel betrayed by being
able to get to other places much much
quicker uh then you probably will agree
with whoever said that otherwise you'll
probably be grateful and happy that you
can get around much much faster because
of this enormous investment
the the problem though with what you've
just said about ignoring these people
you know
the the reason it's difficult for people
to ignore them is because they've
elected them but just on the the point
of increased
increased speed the prime minister said
yesterday in virtually every station
along the line it's either faster of the
same your own document lists 28 routes
by my counting five have faster journey
times under the new plan four have the
same times 19 have worse times you know
five of those are within 10 so you could
say that they're similar so just in in
terms of the assertion that everyone
along this line will be seeing speedier
travel and that's just a lie
um i i don't recognize your figures i've
got two pages here you can see i've torn
them out of the
report uh it lists a lot more places
than you just mentioned right off the
bat so i i don't i don't recognize what
you're saying virtually everywhere gets
much better services than was envisaged
under the original hs2 plan which is to
say other than the fact that
obviously ripped through the countryside
there'd be an awful lot of people this
morning who will be uh relieved
but other than that
there are just massive journey time
improvements and as i say you know a a
half an hour or thereabouts journeys
from manchester to liverpool from
manchester to leeds these are real
improvements oh and there's one other
thing i should mention rather than these
being delivered nev in the never never
time because previously this these
wouldn't have come about the 2040s these
are upgrades which starting this uh
christmas and will be delivered in many
times many cases during this decade so
rather than having to wait forever
people will get the advantages much much
sooner i do encourage people to actually
take a look at the document itself
because i think they'll get a very very
different picture
i would encourage them to do exactly the
same but can we just focus for a second
on the money and the 96 billion pound
figure that that understandably you're
pretty pleased of isn't the truth of
that 42 billion of that has already been
allocated for hs2 from london to
birmingham crew so actually the
additional funds that we're talking
about here are roughly in the the region
of 54 billion i think you'd accept that
but actually
about that and we say that in the
document yes great estimates vary but
with the full hs2 and npr network as you
previously promised we were looking at
perhaps as much as 185 billion now you
may well contest that figure but it is a
statement of fact that as a result of
the u-turn that you and the prime
minister performed tens of billions of
pounds less will be spent in the north
there was never a figure of 185 but i do
broadly speaking accept that if you were
to just do everything that everybody has
ever
mentioned it would come to about 185
billion clearly would not be affordable
in terms of other priorities for the
country and whether you'd have to take
that out of health or education or
welfare or something else
it clearly would never have been uh
delivered at 185 billion pounds and i
just want to repeat the central argument
here first of all when you look at the
figures if you wherever you live in the
country if you're in the midlands or
north take a look at what your journey
times will be you'll see the likely to
be at least the same or largely much
better uh than they are today with
really quick journey times as i
mentioned things like bradford to leads
in 12 minutes which i think people will
massively welcome the second thing is
you won't have to wait until the 2040s
to see these improvements these
improvements will start coming much much
faster in during this decade and again i
think that that matters to people more
than some dream of something which may
never ever occur in so many decades time
and as you rightly point out would
bankrupt the country uh in the meantime
given that both you and the prime
minister have within recent memory
promised that eastern leg of vhs2 which
is not going ahead that new line between
leeds in manchester which is not going
ahead on what basis should we believe
any of the promises that you're making
this morning
okay so we are building here just to
correct you again we are building more
hs2 line on the eastern leg so from
birmingham eastwards uh towards
nottingham to derby by the way unlike
the original plans we'll actually go
town centre to town centre so those are
more journeys that dramatically speed up
they're actually faster between
birmingham uh and naughty and birmingham
uh than you would have had under the
original plans and then with the
upgrades that we're doing the midland
midland main line all across the east
coast the journey times to many of the
locations are identical to the ones that
we would have had uh with uh sort of
full fat hs2 if you like so sheffield
for example and about the same time and
then we are in this plan going to be uh
looking at studying how to get those hs2
trains into leads so i think you're
you're rather rather overselling uh that
disappearing that that is still there
and we're going to do all of this much
much sooner 10 15 years sooner than the
original plan would have delivered so if
you are if you are a rail user and you
are hearing this argument don't take my
word for it don't take your word for it
go and look at the document go and look
at the journey times
and you'll see the massive improvements
which are being provided